à jean michel maire on a décidé de le
piéger et on l'a mis j'ai mis dans une
loge d'un soir et jean michel maire je
vais demander de me parler un petit peu
des chroniques rouge et vous voir vous
allez voir que jean michel maire c'est
quand même un sacré dans l'arbre sacré
salo a poli je n'ai pas voulu dire le
mot regardez oui il y avait des caméras
jean michel maire non j'ai prétexté un
projet en fait de deuxième partie de
soirée
et regardez jean michel maire il
fracasse tout le monde oh non mais bon
aujourd'hui
enfin vous serez content de cette
merveilleuse pour moi je suis justement
je trouve exceptionnel autour de lancer
une nouvelle émission à deux cellules
c'est toi bon des coups de fil
facetime pour direct en direct sur ces
huit troisième partie de soirée
et c'est un peu sexe et je te vois
dedans grave dedans mais je te vois avec
une meuf
or j'avais pensé avec la caroline au
départ ouais je m'entends super bien
avec les jolis les sexy mais je pense
qu'elle a rejetées jure je pense tu veux
trop la pécho donc c'est pas moi j'ai
dit si j'ai aimé tous les soirs ensemble
ça un quart des histoires plus sont
mariés tous ces coins là risquent de le
jouer après ses amis sur wii mais quand
je les télés mais city tout ce le fut
plutôt marrer mais c'est un tocard qui
incarne tu penses de montcalm le zizi
non je suis dit ça comme ça j'imagine
tout le monde si je le dis maintenant
tellement vide a pêché non sans appel
qui ne convient ni neutre
aujourd'hui c'est le vache mais c'est
usant pas comme un côté même d'assurer
le passage de m signé avec daniel moroni
avec tao après j'ai pensé à capucine
tous - labrador sur la samo cilic
non franchement pendant ce temps valérie
matériaux c'est une bleue qu'il fallait
ou non quelques généreux ou lui a trop
mou le défilé valérie aguerris et là il
s est une maman toi c'est ton à la
célèbre bande et le téléspectateur toi
puis nous dit qu à deux sexes tricot
derrien déjà pompiers au battage une
fois seul loin pas l'air d'être de ce
parti pendant qu'on siffle alors je
pense que la meilleure solution c'est
non le staff et des radios avec elle le
seul truc on se parle on attend sa
réponse un peu je savoir toi bergy1
remporté l'émission sur 6,8
ça s'est arrêté sur ses stars compagnie
acceptions que faurie temps vino vers
laquelle ou pas du tout dit la vérité
honnêtement j'espère qu'ils tirent un
peu chez elle je conseille à côté elle
pourrait l'être un comique un
chroniqueur avoir toujours tirer la
couverture à elle moi je moi je
voilà encore un temps d'y travailler
avec quoi parce qu'ils ont commis les
crimes parce que rejouer avec une façade
qui donne tout mais ne serait ce la
meilleure
et puis après on mixe est mort donc toi
tu vas pas du tout être acquérant des
cas que tu va proposer moment non non
non non c'est pas un premier choix mais
ma deuxième pack a des qualités que oui
mais l'égalité merrill et les résultats
sont pas là des quelque 70 morts
[Musique]
passionnant même à côté attend tous les
ténors aussi je fais comme ça il doit
laisser c'était trop qu'à votre ça c'est
souvent la meilleure voix l'a pas fait
ce titre elle est souvent pour cauet
mais melvin thomas était meilleure et
américain human 5 il ya des banlieues
est toujours retenu l'erika et de
racailles et mes couilles je m'étonne
tout le temps de chauffe à l'antenne que
j'ai crevé bien pierné donne comme ça
franchement c'est une fille et un pixel
art alias de ma faute si ça marche grâce
à elle donc après ce qu'ils voient voilà
j'en veux pas de ces bureaux les
burgiens déjà deux peuvent donner 300
sociétés l'amener à la table et noël
aura franchement honnêtement j'adore clé
dans john holmes
[Musique]
valérie valérie non mais je peux pas
croire non faibli dans quoi il y avait
les caméras touche mes mains tout chez
moi à travers le monde qui bosse et je
sais pas ce qui me choque le plus
honnêtement non mais moi j'aimerais déjà
guy reynaud que j'en ai fait des tonnes
ouais je le pense mme armelle est ce que
je dis c'est normal il est vraiment
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai répété plusieurs fois j'adore enoh
aussi voilà fait de la radio mais cette
fois à bout là vous devez alors je vais
laisser la parole à la principale
intéressée s'est quand même et léo la
peau qui s'en est pris que selon un
sondage de l'ombre à sa main en battant
oui parce que tu vas rester à ta place
non mais parce qu'on est on fait de la
télé là il ya un moment donné là c'est
plus la télé quoi là non non mais t'as
ta gueule à un moment donné tu vois là
vraiment puisque les gens veulent que je
me vénère voilà je vais me weiler
vraiment je crois que toi et moi on
était potes bas ont des pages ne le fera
plus jamais jamais je me serais permis
de parler comme toi / sur ce ton comme
ça le bisou au cheval à la personne âgée
la qui pue de la gueule d'un moment ça
va
le let et toutes ont des marges bien
mais bon m'étais fait travailler mon
bloc québécois lui ne rien faire un
bisou mais il nous faut des merguez
0direct décoller j'ai envie chez beijing
en [ __ ] se fait passer pour mon pote
soit 10 on sort machin c'est moi qui la
retint ça à chaque fois
alors tu m'en met plein la gueule à
l'antenne pour que tu es une émission de
c'est d'y jouer pro je vais faire un
pilote avec toi j'ai pas dit qu'on
voulait faire un pilote
ouais bravo
non mais c'est une caméra cachée on
dirait qu est ce que vous appelez cela
on va on va se retrouver dans un instant
les chiroux va voir on va essayer de
calmer droit on se retrouve dans un
instant dans la grande race râler chéri
on est en direct
vous voyez les gens me à lure est très
énervé et m'a trompé et ce qui se passe
je l'aimé trop peur ils hyper mal à
démontrer pas correct d'avoir montré sa
série et nora et ce qu'elle peut rentrer
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose d'un
petit cadeau pour une aura quelque chose
bah oui j'avais prévu mais et enora
est-ce qu'elles pourront entrer doha
elle attend venir et n'aura hélas doit
aller là je pensais pas le millième de
ce que j'ai dit je me suis emballé c'est
à cause aussi cyril jouerions discute
comme ça comme des cons et voilà
franchement je t'adore mais c'est un peu
et l'on veut pas
[Applaudissements]
et toi tu mets dans la gueule ouais non
non et non adresse web
[Applaudissements]
voilà ou alors est ce que je lui dis oui
c'est moi qui t'ai piégée
[Applaudissements]
av et ar
oui
c'est laura cap léger jean michel